[Music]
into the open form questions I know I
sent you a long list of questions this
morning from streamx I think I may take
two or three because I also have to
speak um not too long after this live
stream um but and I also see that Mark
Alex also you put a question in the chat
but we'll take one question from before
and then we'll take your question
brother Mark and welcome Rose to the SDA
church we pray that you are blessed by
this ministry that you will continue to
learn and grow um in the knowledge of
our Lord and savior so we'll take this
question this question comes from
Michael he says I am 23 years old and
from Ghana I have B I have been battling
with the issue of prophets over the
years I would like to know if the 7-Day
Adventist Church aside from the ministry
of Ellen G white has other people who
are called by God to be prophets in
these last days
and 1 Corinthians 12: 28 is quoted which
reads and God had set some in the church
Apostles secondary prophets thirdly
teachers after that Miracles then Gifts
of healings helps governments
diversities of
tongues yes well that's true and this
the Bible shows that to be the case God
has had prophets from Enoch as far as we
ar until Ellen White which is a prophet
in our church the church does not
recognize anyone as a prophet since
white if God sends a prophet to the
church he will somehow let the church
know he doesn't just let some one person
know that's it he will let his church
know through his ordained system and so
we are not aware of any Prophet to the 7
Adventist Church since Ellen White who
passed away in 1915 after 7 years of
faithful service but the gift of
Prophecy has not yet ended God may elect
or choose to raise up someone else but
as far as the church is aware and the
church knows since Ellen White ended her
Ministry or God called her to rest there
has not been a specifically called
Prophet now in in you know these are the
churches everybody's a prophet Prophet
John and Prophet this and Prophet
Denisha everybody's a prophet you see
but God has not raised up a prophet in
this church since El white not someone
the church has recognized now from time
to time even eles did were people
calling themselves prophets and some
leaders would listen to them but the
church has never recognized anyone since
El and the church is God's system for
recognizing when God is doing this or
that so no we don't recognize any other
prophets since El now God speaks to
people in different ways yes but the
discret offic of prophet we've had not
had not had one since Ela white died in
1915 and if you don't know who El white
is please find out read her writing
first book I recommend steps to Christ
please read it steps to
Christ next question this question comes
from by the way let me say this if
someone comes to you saying I'm a
prophet say excuse me and just walk
away
please prophets are not
self-appointed the world is overrun with
self-appointed particularly in Africa
and other places everyone's a prophet if
someone says I'm a prophet you say okay
God bless you walk away before the
person puts error into your head
prophets do not call themselves let me
very clear they are called by God no
Prophet who is any Prophet at all will
come to you saying I am a
prophet that reminds me of Satan's last
great deception when he comes and says
I'm Jesus and
Jesus well he w't be the first one we
have a lot of people who call themselves
Jesus and those who follow them end up
dead in thisg graceful way